today we're going to be speaking with dr
stephen novella who is a neurologist
host and producer of the award-winning
podcast the skeptic's guide to the
universe and also lead author of the
best-selling book by the same name i
really appreciate your time it's great
having you on today
oh thanks for having me on it's great to
be here you've uh the book and the
podcast really these are
excellent sources for thinking about
uh how to evaluate why we believe the
things we believe why others believe the
things they they believe how to engage
with epistemology and critical thinking
which is is so important right now
we could start this conversation any of
of a number of different ways can you
talk a little bit first generally about
the approach you find most useful when
engaging with people with different
views to kind of create a baseline from
which we can have conversations about do
we believe things that are that are
actually true what's the the general
approach that you propose
yeah well i think you know saying that
we need a baseline is a good approach uh
the first step is always to establish
some common ground
because if you don't have common ground
pretty much you're just fighting right
you're not talking you're not engaging
you're not
going to make any progress and you might
have to back up quite a ways to find out
where that common ground is people make
a lot of assumptions they don't even
realize how many different things go
into their world view and how many
assumptions are in there and that
somebody else might not share those same
assumptions so even things like how do
we know what's real or what evidence is
reliable evidence
etc yeah once and once you establish
that common ground you might you might
actually also be surprised to find how
that you have a lot more common ground
than you may think that's that's another
common experience and then you can build
slowly carefully from there uh you know
what are the goals
what you know what how are we going to
figure out you know how to how to
proceed here uh so that i think there's
a general picture if you just back up
and find common ground that's a good way
to begin there are some pitfalls
sometimes in a lot of these
conversations and i'm curious as to your
thoughts about how to navigate them you
know there's these concepts that are
often bandied about like dunning krueger
the idea that someone lacks
the
ability or knowledge to understand that
they are not necessarily fully equipped
to have a certain conversation which
which comes off as very uh insulting
sometimes to say to someone in whatever
words you want to use you know
dunning-kruger may be limiting your
ability to engage meaningfully in this
conversation
the the reality is sometimes people are
kind of in over their heads so what what
are some more
productive ways maybe to establish that
someone may just not have all of the
information to engage
yeah so you know i think the first
realization is that dunning-kruger
and uh the logical fallacies critical
thinking skills you know media literacy
these things don't apply to other people
they apply to you they apply to everyone
so if you're using you know these
critical thinking concepts as a weapon
in order to
you know essentially knock down or
attack somebody else you're doing it
wrong you know these mainly are um
methods of policing your own thinking
and so like don and krueger it doesn't
mean some people are like don't have the
information to evaluate
their ignorance it's everybody does just
to a different degree degree on
different topics but unless you are at
the cutting edge of world expertise in a
very you know narrow topic
it applies to you there you don't have
enough information to really
meaningfully engage
in you know
how we know what we know about some
cutting-edge tech especially technical
topic
um and so the the other half of that is
what we call neuropsychological humility
right so that we all have to be humble
i'm not saying that like you're dumb or
you can't
you know engage in critical thinking or
there are you're cognitively biased it's
we all are we all need to confront the
way our brains work the way our logic
tends to work and
you know again this gets back to the con
to the common ground things like we all
need to work together to identify the
limitations in our knowledge identify
maybe some of the biases that we're
working with and then again see if we
can build from there to to some kind of
common ground
one of the things that particularly
during the pandemic often comes up
and i get a lot of emails from people
about this as well is someone will say
yeah okay so the cdc and the who and my
local doctor they say this
but did you see that like gary null for
example is a name that people often
email me about or they'll say or dr john
campbell on youtube said this about
ivermectin or whatever
and sometimes i have the instinct like
when callers say this stuff
to talk a little bit about credentials
like to say well you you know dr john
campbell he has a doctorate in teaching
nursing he's not a medical doctor but at
the same time i know that it's sort of
an appeal to authority but i recognize
it might be relevant for someone to know
whether we're talking to a medical
doctor or not like it seems relevant but
at the same time it's kind of just like
going right to credentials
what what makes sense when it comes to
something like that
this is perhaps the trickiest thing that
we engage with because it's basically
dueling experts right and you can find
an expert to say whatever you want to
support whatever position you you want
to have and you feel like i'm listening
to the experts i got these experts over
here and this phenomenon has been
weaponized it's not like it's just a
random thing there are people who are
trying to lead you down a path paved
with these you know cherry-picked
outlier expert opinions or pseudo expert
opinions or sometimes they're not
experts at all um and you know you have
to be able to pick your way through that
but again if you're not an expert
how do you do that again you're not in a
position to evaluate which experts are
legitimate so you need to have some
basic algorithms that you use some basic
things you know
red flags or processes that you go
through to have at least a reasonable
way of evaluating people who have more
expertise in an area than you do
so
i think probably the biggest uh thing to
do is to listen to a consensus of many
experts over an opinion of one expert no
one expert is definitive every any one
person can be wrong could be a complete
outlier but if you have
you know
uh organizations that have some
legitimacy like they're not an
ideological organization or like you
know um
exist for for the purpose of pushing an
agenda but they're like a university or
a professional organization etc and they
say yeah we put together a panel of
experts and they recommend this this is
how they like the american medical
association for example or you know any
other like medical professional
organization who say yeah we reviewed
the evidence and this this is the
standard of care that we think is the
case or
you know the intergovernmental you know
panel on climate change yeah we have 3
000 climate scientists got together and
they go yeah this is 95 likely what's
going on
you know you can't
put that up against one you know
one person as an expert in isolation and
say that they're equivalent
um so i think that's if you just did
that just sought out
you know what seemingly objective um
consensus opinion among the greatest
number of experts possible you're much
more likely to be correct than listening
to one guy on youtube no matter what his
credentials seem to be when it comes to
medications would it be rather than what
one person says or a a small study one
doctor did saying the standard is sort
of like the randomized controlled trial
and that that would be what we look to
yeah well that's certainly now you're
saying what what is the standard of
evidence within that field right so
certainly with with drugs and with a lot
of medical treatments the standard is
the randomized um trial
but it's more than that actually it's a
systematic review of multiple randomized
controlled trials gotcha one trial
doesn't really tell you anything because
any one trial could be a quirky result
it could be you know you don't know what
the pattern is statistically speaking
you can't make many firm conclusions
based on one study but once you see what
the pattern of evidence is among many
studies and that requires an expert
systematic review which is a great way
by the way to get a good quick idea of
what is the consensus of opinion about
this medical topic is look at some you
know high quality systematic reviews
you know then that tells you what's
likely to be the case because then
you're seeing a pattern of evidence not
just one piece of evidence
right now
what set of false factually false
beliefs i'm not using the term
conspiracy theory because sometimes it's
not really a conspiracy theory it's just
people believe something that's not true
what what's the most concerning or
to you or that you believe is most
damaging to us
in society right now
well i mean certainly anti-vaccine
attitudes are incredibly harmful
especially in the middle of a pandemic i
mean it's definitely slowing down and
impairing our ability to tamp down
this pandemic
increasing the odds that new variants
are going to emerge and prolong you know
the pandemic so that's definitely you
know in the short term that's probably
the biggest thing long term i have to
say climate change you know we need to
be the conversation we need to be having
is how best to avoid the worst case
scenarios of climate change how how to
mitigate the the expensive you know and
very disruptive effects that are that
are already happening and are and we
know we're going to be getting worse
rather than the endless discussion of is
it happening or you know trying to do
whatever we can to avoid
you know reducing fossil fuel company
profits which is i think what most of
the you know the pushback is really all
about um we sort of get stuck
spinning our wheels and again that's
that's on purpose that's by design you
know
it literally there are paid
pr experts who spread you know fear
uncertainty and doubt to delay things as
much as possible it's just so easy for
that to happen
because you know it's just easy to
generate the sort of false skepticism
this uh
you know what i call science denial uh
in order to prolong the discussion in
this preliminary phase of is it
happening is there anything we can do
about it and then of course to sort of
nitpick and shoot down any proposed
solutions rather than engage
meaningfully with
you know what is the best solutions you
know to this problem what will minimize
any short-term negative economic impact
what's going to have the greatest chance
of succeeding term etc and there's lots
of great you know proposals
on the table and it's happening it's
just we just need to accelerate it so
that we can
you know again avoid um risking some
tipping points or or the worst outcome
so in the long run for humanity i think
that's the biggest you know issue that
we're facing there are people who
sometimes categorize false beliefs with
a very fine line between them the sort
of the ones that are materially damaging
like you point out climate science
denial preventing us from actually
putting in place you know some real
infrastructure here to deal with this or
anti-vax is
literally it prolonging a a
pandemic and then they'll say okay and
then there's a fine line and on the
other side there's stuff that's
basically benign like flat earth for
example yeah
i've spoken to
psychologists who specialize in um
paranoid and conspiracist beliefs and
and different people who say it's not
really that fine of a line because often
something seemingly benign like flat
earth belief
is associated with people with
anti-semitic conspiracy theories that
they believe or there's overlap with the
anti-vaxx movement or whatever can you
give us your sense of whether there
really are these two categories or
whether it's much more of a gray area
oh there's there aren't two categories
it's all just a continuum of one thing
okay there's there's certainly more or
less direct harm or demonstrable harm
from certain belief systems like if you
believe that modern medicine is a
conspiracy you know and and you should
treat all things with with uh
prayer or drinking your own urine or
whatever something bizarre like that
people actually believe by the way uh
then that yeah that's sort of a you
could easily easily see how immediately
harmful that can be
uh there's the other beliefs are like
flat earther for example you may or
belief in ghosts is one we all who cares
if people believe in ghosts it's the the
harm is not as obvious
but it's still there um you may need to
dig a little bit to see what the
tangible physical harm is but there's
also epistemological harm right when
people believe in magic when they are
don't understand the basics of how
science is working when they believe
it's all a conspiracy you are setting
them up for the harmful conspiracy to
come the more immediate obviously
harmful thing um so and sometimes it's
not that
long a trip there if you so if you
believe in magic you believe in you know
astrology or whatever
then you may are you're much more likely
to be
hoodwinked by let's say um a psychic who
you know we know there are fraudulent
psychics out there who steal millions of
dollars from people i mean it's that's
not harmless
so you know
the the harm may be a little bit more
secondary and harder to quantify
but it's it's there and when you do this
you know for a living for a long time
you see you see the harm
you know even if it's a little bit
downstream uh there's tremendous harm
from believing in magic it makes you
incredibly vulnerable it is not isolated
and so you know we should not think of
these things as benign at all
do we all have some of these beliefs
like for example i think of myself as
someone who follows science and i ask
myself why do i believe this or that but
just like to pick something random
oftentimes when i'm traveling somewhere
new and eating some food i've not had
i'll mention i really hope this doesn't
make me sick and i think on some level i
think that by mentioning it
i'm kind of like putting it out and it's
like less likely that a weird new food
in some new country will i don't really
believe that i know that the thing i say
doesn't actually make a difference but
it's sort of like one of these it's a
false belief it doesn't really have an
impact on whether a food will make me
sick do we all have some of these things
do you think
oh sure so if you're you know no one is
intellectually pristine right so
you know
humans are predisposed to um
superstitious thinking like what you're
saying and sometimes you know we engage
in that for fun or for comfort
uh or for because of tradition or ritual
when we know intellectually like yes
there's no magic here this is not
actually true i cannot ward off food
poisoning by saying i hope this isn't
poisonous but you still do it that's i
mean that's i think is benign if you
know intellectually this is not true
and it's just part of just human
behavior
although you know some people like to
police that within themselves as well
just
you know do because they think it could
help keep their keep their critical
thinking skills focused which is fine as
well
um but also in terms of what we actually
believe no one's you know belief system
is or what they hold to be true is
perfect either right it's just
impossible to get to that point where
yes i purged myself of all inaccurate
conclusions and false beliefs and i
everything i believe is 100 you know
accurate true and precise
that's that's an aspirational goal that
we will never get to the real difference
between people are those who engage in
metacognition and those who don't what's
metacognition it's basically thinking
about thinking it's turning a analytical
eye towards your own thinking processes
and trying to understand how you come to
conclusions how you come to believe
things examining improving tweaking that
process being open to changing your
beliefs based upon evidence and logic
etc and those people who don't really
actively engage in metacognition they
sort of go with their psychological
process level they're just sort of they
they're following the the current you
know the mental current to whatever
conclusion it brings them to
and not examining the process so you're
never going to be somebody who's
whose beliefs are pristinely perfect but
you can be somebody who examines
everything they believe and is willing
to change their mind and so again we say
it's a journey it's a process if you
live your life as somebody who can get
less and less wrong you know over time
that's the best you can do
but it's better than remaining in a
position where you're not even examining
your beliefs and you're just going with
with whatever your your id is telling
you to believe that that makes a lot of
sense last thing i want to talk about
changing other people's minds
there are many folks i've spoken to who
say
uh at the wholesale like at a societal
level when we see rapid changing of
minds it's often coming at the hands of
authoritarianism dictatorship the
chinese cultural revolution etc if we
think more at the retail level of
individuals it's building relationships
and often applying a sort of socratic
type method of questioning to get other
people to say hey maybe i'm not as
solidly grounded in this belief as i
thought i was
do you agree that that is a good method
and
it seems like it's it takes a very long
time to change minds well yeah so that
that's it depends on context and people
ask us this question all the time and
say well who what's your relationship
what are your goals what what's your
investment
if you're playing the long game right
this is somebody that you have a
long-term relationship with
etc or you know even if on on a a
wholesale level where you're trying to
influence culture or organizations or
institutions
you can you have to play the long game
you know you can't just brow beat
somebody with a belief and and expect
them to change their mind it's far
better to just give them critical
thinking skills establish a little
baseline of scientific literacy some
media savvy and let them come to that
conclusion by themselves sometimes a
good way to do this is again find common
ground i like to say you just find
something that someone is skeptical
about and ask them why they're skeptical
about that you don't so you're saying
you don't believe in ancient astronauts
or whatever pick something find
something they don't believe in say why
don't you believe in that right and then
you they will usually you know
give a pretty skeptical reason for what
that there's no evidence it doesn't make
any sense or whatever i said that's
right you're and then you just engage
them engage their skepticism
and
try to to nurture that grow that and
generalize those skills you know and
once they see that's right people
believed this and that was wrong
and how could that how does that work
and they you know they begin to
generalize their skepticism and then
eventually they'll turn it more inward
and hopefully
you know more and more things will fall
event you know to really hardcore
skeptics like all belief falls
eventually like everything gets
subjected to the skeptical the skeptical
eye
so that's the goal but that is
absolutely the long game that's years
you know it's a process you and even for
seasoned skeptics we still will fall
prey to emotional beliefs or
misinformation or not realize that we're
being ideological when we think we're
being when we think we're being logical
it's hard it's not it's not easy though
it's a complicated world and there's a
lot of misinformation out there
and our brains are really flawed you
know at doing this we we're only
semi-rational creatures
um so it's at best it's a process but um
you know if you engage in it either
personally or with other people trying
to to you know get them to be more
skeptical it's a lifelong process that's
interesting i mean thinking out loud
about an issue that we're dealing with
right now which is people blaming joe
biden for a lot of things that either
happened before he was president or that
are happening in other countries rather
than the approach of well what did he do
to cause that i wonder if there would be
something to saying hey listen do you
blame joe biden for the challenger
disaster and most people would probably
say well no i don't and maybe there's an
opportunity to say well why not and they
might give some reasons which then would
also apply to some of the areas that
they're blaming him today
yeah that's that's a good approach i i
like to take the approach
myself you know for myself but also to
other people it's like imagine if there
were a president of your party president
right now
and this were happening
what would you say
just do the thought experiment right you
just say oh yeah i would totally blame
them for everything just as much as i
would you really but think about it
really put yourself in that position
and just say you know if you had to that
and that's sort of the devil's advocate
approach like if you had to defend the
other position what would you say
a great always a great thought
experiment it gets people engaging with
the other side and then they and then
you know pretty soon like yeah you know
just getting them to think that way
makes them think that way that's the
psychologists have demonstrated that
frequently just if you tell people to
take to just pretend they have a
position they actually move towards that
position if you tell people just pretend
we're thinking skeptically here for a
minute
and then and then do that as an exercise
it actually gets them thinking more
skeptically that's super interesting
that that's a that's a very good idea uh
we've been speaking with dr steven
novella who is the host and producer of
the award-winning podcast the skeptic's
guide to the universe and lead author of
the book by the same name such a
pleasure having you on i really
appreciate it
a lot of fun thanks for having me